for the people out there they're like
what do you mean this guy owned a ran a
hotel and oh now it's hotels what's it
actually like owning and running a hotel
most people's dream to own a house run
your house
you're running a hotel and it at the
well the first one was 30 rooms and then
the next one was like 300 rooms and now
you've had x amount of hotels since so
what's it like being a hotel owner and
operator
you know i think
again i look at every business as zeros
so a third of a hotel and a 300 motel
it's one more zero it's just times 10.
so the answer is they're opposite
animals right one is a simple project
one's a big project but
you know i think it's fun right like
it's it's the same practice yeah 30
motel needs
10 housekeepers 300 miles needs 20 like
you just have to gauge the numbers um
but it's it's a fun business
it's a tough business because you're
open
365 days a year seven days a week like
you don't close there's no sorry hotel
closes like you're you're just open so
it's a it's a challenging business
you're dealing with labor people
personalities guests staff
there's a lot that goes into it it's a
very tough business
um
but it's a business that if you love you
do it if you don't love that business
you don't do it it's extremely extremely
challenging uh what advice do you have
when someone's booking a hotel
right all right i'm looking to go travel
i'm looking to buck a book a hotel give
me a little secret that someone should
know when they're looking online looking
for a hotel you have any tips of the
trade of best day to book best time to
book you should work book a week out two
weeks out three month day of you got any
secret sauce you want to give to the
people
i don't
honestly i don't like you're playing it
close to the vest no my secret sauce is
if you book a hotel become friends with
the staff so like if you book
i don't know called the ritz carlton in
bahamas tomorrow
it's not bad call the front desk
introduce yourself hi i'm checking in on
this day to this day do you see my
reservation sure oh great what room do i
have you know moving for an upgrade like
become friends with the staff because
they're the they're the buttons that can
change anything i actually totally agree
with you it's not so much
tips to booking the hotel it's that once
it's been booked
that's when you can kind of pick up the
phone hey i'm coming in that's my trick
correct
got it um
do you has it the experience of staying
in other hotels been kind of
ruined for you because you know all of
the inner workings and you have a higher
expectations like
after being a server
every time i go to a restaurant i'm a
little bit like i know you just didn't
put my food in or i know you could be
doing better but i also have more
empathy as well when things are hectic
so just do you find that like when you
go to places now you're like looking
through your
hotelier eyes a fun word to say this is
a fun word to say
so i love hotels in fact i think i live
i've lived in hotels for probably the
last
you know 10 years my last 20 years of
graduating college so i live in hotels i
love hotels um i love and i strive for
service so that's my thing is like i i
always book good place to stay but i
love service and i love great service i
love when
staff is happy so like to me like that's
my
thing like if i go somewhere and
service is off it's like that's the only
action like why is it off like get my
own server stay here don't leave keep me
my friends happy or my family happy so i
think service is the one thing that i'm
very adamant about because keep on being
a server a server in a good mood or
serve in a bad mood two different
experiences
and to me it's like if your vibe's off
why are you even around me just give me
this person so i you know yeah like like
i look at it like that and by the way
like there's been times i've been out to
restaurant place and someone's
attitude's off and i'll tell the
bartender like
your attitude's kind of off i don't draw
anybody but like just let me deal with
that guy today the nice way yeah yeah
because if not it ruins your whole vibe
your whole experience is off so
i think service the one thing i always
try to
get and demand the best of eight fun
fact israel doesn't have any michelin
stars because
the service is always not good enough
they have incredible restaurants all
over israel incredible food but they
don't have any measuring stars because
you will have to ask for water
five times before you get it yeah
you know not to throw any shade but you
they also don't get paid like and the
tipping is much lower so they don't
they're not working for it but just how
important service is that doesn't matter
how good the food is
they're like yeah whoever serves it to
you can i get a little water
go get the water yourself
what do you mean
can you check out my food you'll go
check it
[Music]